that wide variety of placement with an
industry is something unique to our
programs and that is a result of the
interdisciplinary nature of our graduate
programs I really like that it it's not
just narrowly focused so I mean I'm
interested in security but you know I'm
also interested in computer science and
you know other related fields too I
really like the fact that you have that
flexibility the main thing to understand
is the freedom they're going to have to
make the program be whatever you want it
to be I chose the internship option and
I think that was very valuable for me
because this was my first industrial
experience you actually get a feel of
how it is going to be working in the
industry and about whether this is the
kind of work that you want to do or not
the information networking Institute
last year had the highest placement rate
of all graduates across this university
we had a hundred percent placement rate
and of the highest starting salaries
within the university this is something
that has happened over the past few
years is a lot of business and finance
companies have started looking for
students who have had taken technical
courses they are really interested in
hiring students who have that kind of a
background so you actually get really
prepared instead of fields and you get
interaction with real business and real
companies they do about four or five
networking events a year in different
cities it's very helpful for for
networking and finding other people that
work in the various cities when when you
want to go and decide what career path
you want to go down there's quite a few
benefits to being a Carnegie Mellon
alumni first there's the Carnegie Mellon
name I mean people recognize the name
secondly I think the alumni networks are
are really really powerful I think the
biggest advantages the education that we
get and the fact that once you graduate
from the ini you have really a
unbelievable solid foundation that any
employer would love to have
you